[Musique]
5S som rencontr avec Laurent et Claude
un festival folk traditionn et comme
Laur jou de son côté moi du bien on
s'est réuni on a dit on va faire de la
musique ensemble et comme je connaissais
Irène depuis j' éta en classe avec et je
savais qu'elle jouait du folk plutôt du
folk américain anglais est venu avec
nous et nous sommes avons fait dès le
départ de la musique flamande musique
qui était assez peu connue à cette
époque-là puisque le renouveau du folk
flamand date de quelques années
simplement
[Musique]
allô oui descendant d'heureuse et de
forgeron martial wer anime le centre
socio-éducatif d'asbrook oui c'est que
l'association
Claude cl dit
cocotte et sa fille
Rachelle Laurent cl joue de plusieurs
instruments de musique et en vend
d'autres
très bonne
mécanique
aussiender il y a éidation de
[Musique]
Fender Irène van derberg enseigne dans
la banliol
l'îoise allez salut
[Musique]
dépêche la musique fol que flamande
c'était surtout avant considéré comme
une musique à boire comm une musique
rapprochante la musique tyrolienne un
petit peu alors que pas du tout ça les
gens connaissai ne connaissaient plus le
le musique traditionnelle et on l'a
redécouvert et puis on a jou ensemble
voilà un petit peu comment ça s passé
tout
[Musique]
simplement
M
[Musique]
vive alle
de
[Musique]
group c'est essayer de rester le plus
possible dans la vie populaire afin de
pas faire une musique disons plaquée sur
la sur la population donc pour ça nous
avons essayé le plus possible de nous
intégrer à la vie des fêtes à la vie des
traditions en Flandre notamment dans des
fêtes comme la la fête de Saint-Martin
qui est une fête traditionnelle en en
Flandre française puisqu'on la retrouve
dans pas mal de villes et cette fête au
sein du foyer rural de godwfeld qui est
un petit cercle dans lequel nous sommes
intégrés et dans lequ nous essayons de
travailler pour les traditions
populaires donc au sein de ce ce foyer
rural nous avons essayé de faire revivre
cette fête enfin de pas même pas la
faire revivre d'aider à la continuité de
cette fête puisqu'elle est restée très
vivace et même sans nous elle ser resté
aussi vivace alors la fête de
Saint-Martin est assez particulière
puisqu'il s rattache une une légende
Saint-Martin quand quand il est venu
dans les Flandres a perdu son âne et
pour rechercher son son son âne les
enfants ont creusé des betteraves et ont
fait des lanterne avec pour rechercher
dans la campagne l'âme de Saint-Martin
et de là est resté la tradition de la
fête de la
[Musique]
Saint-Martin
en dehors des fêtes traditionnelles
telles que les fêtes de Saint-Martin ou
les fêtes de Ducas de tout le village
des fêtes votive donc qui se déroulent
dans les villages se déroul dans les
dans les cabarets dans les cafés qui
étaient très nombreux en Flandre
puisqueà chaque carrefour à chaque rue
se situé plusieurs cafés ce qu'on
appelait des ducasses staminés qui était
la fête en fait du quartier et même la
fête du café et lors de ces fêtes les
gens se rassemblaient pour évidemment
boire dans les cafés mais aussi jouer
aux jeux traditionnels flamand tel que
la boule la boule plate d'extérieur la
boule d'intérieur les fléchettes le tir
à l'arc enfin de des des jeux
traditionnels et ces tucass estaminé
avaient un succès tout non démenti à
chaque année puisque régulièrement à
date fixe on savait qu'à tel café il y
avait une fête et la tradition s
perputué jusque nos jours puisque dans
des cafés comme le refuge du renard on
retrouve encore un peu la même ambiance
que les fait d'autre
fois le refuge du renard a toujours été
un endroit typique depuis longtemps les
gens sont réunis pour chanter sont
réunis pour danser pour parler pour
jouer aux cartes enfin pour faire en
fait la fête
quoi c'est
[Musique]
P ah Julia c'est un personnage puisque
c'est une dame qui a maintenant dans les
80 ans et qui a toujours tenu ce ce café
depuis est toute petite a toujours été
là et puis on va chez Julia on va ref du
renard pour voir Julia parce que c'est
c'est un
personnage
au départ on ne faisait que des des
champs on faisait que du concert et bien
vite on s'est mis à faire ce qu'on
appelle maintenant le bal folk ou la
balle traditionnelle et maintenant on
est presque spécialisé en balle
traditionnelle parce que c'est
c'est une manifestation qui fait
participer tout le monde et où tout le
monde peut danser tout le monde peut
participer alors que le concert c'est
plutôt une représentation où les gens
restent assis ils écoutent passivement
les gens préfèrent peut-être venir au
bal traditionnel parce qu'ils retrouvent
une ambiance ils se retrouvent entre eux
et retrouve à passer c'est pas le le bal
disco disons mais de plus en plus les
gens viennent au bal traditionnel de
plus en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus
he
bra
bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo j'aime bien jouer accordéon j'en
joue assez mal malheureusement mais
j'aime bien jouer l'accordéo et le
tambour un instrument superbe tambour
parce que c'est un instrument de rythme
et la mandoline aussi enfin je joue ces
trois instruments là part de préférence
c'est difficile à dire c'est un petit
peu tous les instruments moi j'aime
jouer l'accordéon chromatique ça pose un
petit problème c'est que c'est très
fatiguant parce que c'est un vieil
instrument d'origine et souffl est un
peu percé là voir ça il y a la vielle et
je me repose un peu en jouant de la
vielle d'ailleurs et j'aimerais surtout
apprendre à jouer de
l'épinetteire moi je joue de la
coramande qui
est é plus ancré dans toute la région
quiant commence à être à reprendre de
l'ampleur dans toute la région du violon
également bien que nous ayons pas
retrouvé à l'heure actuelle dans le
collectage que nous faisons des des
vieux violonistes qui jou des air
flamands mais on croit que c'est un
instrument qui marche très bien avec
disons les harmoniques de notre musique
donc la cor muse le
violon je crois que c'est les
instruments disons qui rentrent dans le
groupe en tant que soliste moi j'aime
bien jouer la la guitare et le Pipo je
pratique pas assez
mais que ce sont les deux que je préfère
jou il y a 2 ans à l'université flamand
d'été il y avait l'atelier de culture
qui s'adressait à la fois à l'histoire à
la au chant ou à la musique et on s'est
aperçu que personne n'avait collecté
depuis depuis des années des champs
traditionnels depuis dekousmerer il y a
100 ans alors que beaucoup de champs
restent dans les mémoires alors nous
sommes assemblés avec toutes les
personnes intéressées par ce travail
nous avons à peu près 300 mélodies ou
chants qui ont été collectés et que nous
essayons de remettre sur partition sur
bande magnétique afin que tous les
groupes toutes les personnes de de
fendre puissent y avoir accès le but ce
n'est pas de faire une collection qu'on
laisse bien tranquille dans un dans un
rayon de bibliothèque mais le but c'est
que les gens reprennent ces chansons et
qui recrée la musique
traditionnelle
[Musique]
Benj